hi everyone welcome to the homeroom live
stream sal here from khan academy super
excited about uh the conversation we're
going to have today but before we get
started i will give my standard
announcements uh first of all a reminder
that we are not for profit and we can
only exist through philanthropic
donations from folks like yourself so if
you're in a position to do so please
think about going to khan academy.org
slash donate and make a donation of any
level it all makes a huge difference
we've been running at a deficit
pre-covenant that deficit has only grown
as we've gone through this crisis and uh
with that in mind i'd like to give a
special shout out to several
organizations that have stepped up to
help us close our gap a special thanks
to bank of america google.org at t
fascinating of artists and the amgen
foundation and and many others who've
supported khan academy through the years
to allow us to be in a position to help
folks teachers parents students through
the covid crisis but we do need more
help so anything you can do much
appreciated so with that i'm super
excited to introduce our guest today
there's a lot to talk about uh we have
lily eskelson garcia president of the
national education association uh the
largest teachers union in the country is
that right or or
uh
thanks so much for joining us lily
thanks so much for joining us
it's an honor thank you for having me
so so maybe a good place to start
obviously all the conversation and this
isn't you know normally this is you know
we have these education conversations
but this has turned into a national
conversation or international
conversation about the state of school
closures or school openings and safety
just
where is your mind right now where are
we in the process how are y'all thinking
about it uh what are y'all advocating
for what do you see is actually
happening and how is it going to play
out over the next few weeks or months
well so it's really why i was so excited
to be on this show
because there's so much misinformation
out there about it seems like everything
uh
so first i want to say um there is no
one probably other than their parents
uh who want those kids back and in
person learning more more than their
teachers and all of the the counselors
and the school nurse and everybody we
want our kids back but we want to go
back
in that school building when
and where
we can do it without
someone dying you know
that i even have to say that out loud is
a little weird but i i noticed when i
was subtle and i'd say you know without
someone getting sick
bottom line is it's a global pandemic
out there there's something in the air
swirling around that's killing people
right thousands and thousands of people
uh
have their lungs attacked it's
impossible for them to breathe it's a
horrible way to die
and we
don't
we don't seem to all be getting that
medical professionals have told us that
the most dangerous place to be in this
global pandemic is in a closed poorly
ventilated building with lots of people
crowding together breathing on each
other hour after hour day after day
which is the description of my sixth
grade classroom the year i had 39 kids
so
i worried on any given day that if
someone you know coughed in the back of
the room i was gonna catch their cold i
knew it three times a year i was gonna
get somebody's cold
this is not that this is quite different
this means somebody coughs and i end up
in the icu
somebody coughs on their best friend
and this kid is infected and
asymptomatic
and goes home and hugs his babysitter
who's his babysitter grandma
and we know now
with some
um
there's new information coming out all
the time this is still so new but that
we have people who say kids can't get
sick kids are immune the president
governors the secretary of education
lots of people giving really bad
information
um we now know that not only can kids
get sick not only can kids end up in the
hospital but a disproportionate amount
of those kids who are ill
are minority children they're black and
brown children they're from immigrant
communities
they
are at greater risk
and so they're also
in the schools with the oldest buildings
with the poorest ventilation the most
overcrowded classrooms
we have to understand that this is
dangerous to children
and it is dangerous to their families
and it is dangerous to their teachers
and
i am an excellent
very very good sixth grade teacher you
would want your kid in my sixth grade um
i'm not an infectious disease medical
professional so when i need to know
something about that
i
hear what dr fauci is saying or public
health professionals
they're
not saying anything different they are
all together the scientific community
the only thing we can do right now is
try not to infect each other
because if we do people die
so they're saying
you don't even think about opening a
school
a restaurant a movie you don't go
to a rally
um
you
until you've got this infection rate
under control
it's now skyrocketing it's it's uh
exploding in more and more places
instead of fewer and fewer places
and so we're really worried about these
one-size-fits-all
open up the school stuff those kids back
in why
we need to get our jobs numbers up we
need their parents back
it's gonna backfire
it's gonna backfire and they will be
doing what they're already doing in
those premature openings
kids are getting sick they're infecting
the community
everybody and
now they're having to close the schools
the chaos
uh the uh insecurity that families are
going through
um it's a crisis let's treat it like a
crisis listen to the people who know
what they're talking about
you know that makes
a ton of sense and it's your point a lot
of it it's it's you know amazing that we
we have to articulate it um because it
makes so much sense how do you think
this plays out and then you mentioned
kind of this
fits all everyone open schools by you
know no matter what doesn't make sense
especially where we are in the pandemic
and then the incidence rate and and some
of these early cases that we're seeing
you know the school season hasn't even
the school year hasn't even started yet
or so it's the very early stages in
several places uh but we're already
seeing these cases as soon as they
opened up within three four days 200
students 800 students whatever um
people people are testing positive
is
i guess there's two questions one is are
there not one-size-fits-all solutions
that could get us a little bit closer to
this uh whether it's hybrid you know
could we use outdoor learning i know
what during the tuberculosis crisis last
century they did a lot of outdoor
schooling are there things that we can
do or are there incidence rates in
certain communities at which point you
know the epidemiologists are telling you
that yeah at that rate and maybe if you
take the right precautions and maybe if
you use outdoor well it might be okay
what are you seeing there
so
i'm seeing some of the most creative
educators in the world uh who are really
um trying to say all right so
distance how are we going to distance uh
disinfect we're not talking about a
little windex you know we're talking
about disinfecting using some pretty uh
specific things and by the way little
kids i love them i loved those 39 kids
they are little germ factories all right
so they are they are touching their
noses and they're touching their little
grubby knits everywhere so it's it's
especially important um that we have a
protocol on disinfecting do we have the
masks uh and do we have the ability to
do um some serious uh screening as kids
come into the building uh where do they
have a cough a temperature are we doing
any kind of even group and random uh
covered testing
so all of the above are what the disease
uh professionals are saying we have to
do but here's the important thing and we
i've seen some of the most creative
here's how we're going to distance those
kindergarteners how are you going to
keep kinder hula hoops
really yes as one of my uh one of my
members she said
uh we're using creative use of space
instead of having 20 kindergarteners
we're putting like eight to 10 in a room
we took out all the all the desks and we
put hula hoops and pillows on the floor
and that's their space and they don't go
out of their hula hoop space um they're
not going to wear the mask little kids
that's a toy uh so we're they're wearing
uh space helmets but they're going to
the moon and they've got the plexi glass
helmets they're doing what they can with
what they have which isn't a lot
but here's what i want people to know
folks keep forgetting the most important
part
the number of
the infection rate in your community is
going to be the infection rate of the
people walking into that building the
teacher lives in the neighborhood those
kids and their families live in those
neighborhoods that
school is a reflection of what's going
on in the broader community
and so if you have
like they had in new orleans a 20 or 25
infection rate
you can probably bet that 25
of the big and little people that walk
into that school
are going to be infected by coven only
this time you're putting them in these
classrooms that have poor ventilation
that
even with your hula hoops um they're
gonna be passing each other in the hall
uh that's why the first thing and it's
the thing most people say yeah well we
don't really care about that you care
about the community infection rate until
you get it down to about five percent
where it's manageable where you can say
maybe five percent of the folks coming
into this school and we can screen for
them we can screen uh and and do some
health checks for them but that's the
most important part and it's the part
that's out of our hands all the hula
hoops and face masks in the world will
not help a surging
um virus rate and so that's what we're
worried about is that folks are looking
at this list infection rates masks
disinfectants distancing and there's
people who don't really know what
they're doing saying well let's do the
masks and the plexiglas
uh but we're not we don't know how to
distance the kids and yeah we're got a
30 infection rate we can't do anything
about it so let's just pick and choose
what might be easiest most convenient
least expensive it doesn't work that way
this is complicated it's hard
and it's expensive if you're going to do
it right
i was alarmed when i heard
the president say well i looked at the
guidance that's cost a lot of money and
you know i told them to go back and
rewrite it
that's not how it works don't do that
listen to the people who are trying to
save our lives
and um and why wouldn't we listen to
them so number one i'm a little mad okay
i'm very angry about a lot of
politicians local state and national
who told folks we don't have to have a
plan it'll go away it's magic
nope it's science it's really science
and uh
what they didn't do
in january and february
is the result is that we've prolonged
this we
are the outlier in the united states
of america there are countries
who do not have an infection
got it very
and we
and now
um i'm getting questions like
what are you going to do teachers
to make sure
we can still keep them safe
what's your plan b
i don't have one
i mean what you're describing is it's
not a fair question to ask a teacher
what
politicians
and what you're describing makes
all the sense in the world you know we
had randy weingarten your peer at the
national federation of teachers saying
essentially the same things you know you
have to take basic precautions do
contact tracing and then get your
infection rate in a community down to a
certain threshold at which point you
know what your point you're making and
randy weingarten made is that like it's
not that people are saying that it has
to be risk-free obviously even in
pre-covet there's all sorts of risks in
our life but it just has to become a
reasonable risk and it's not just about
teachers or students this is about the
community this is just epidemic
epidemiologically sound i have trouble
saying that word for the entire for the
entire community so you know we we
actually had dr fauci on the same live
stream and the best that i could
understand when you know when i asked
him the questions of how this is all
going to play out it really feels like
the most optimistic scenario is one of
these vaccines that are currently in
phase three
which we've already started
manufacturing essentially speculatively
that they might hopefully get six you
know prove effective in the december
january time frame at which point we
have this massive logistical challenge
of distributing hundreds of millions of
doses of vaccine and we don't know to
what degree they'll work or how people
take it simultaneously you have the
therapeutic lens where hopefully some
therapies will come out in the january
february time frame where covet can be
less deadly
less severe hopefully we get to some of
those things but any way you look at it
everyone i've talked we had the ceo of
novartis on this uh live stream as well
they're all saying it's kind of a year
uh that we're in this world uh that
you've just described
and so how is how are you thinking about
it how do you think the education how do
you think educators should think about
what looks like it could be
at least a full school year of some form
of distance learning
and
first of all we were so thrilled that
the uh house of representatives and who
says they're ever thrilled with anything
that congress does but we were actually
thrilled uh that they listened to us and
they said yes you prepare for
um the the face mass and the
disinfectant then yes we need all these
things and please don't make us have to
lay off the school nurse all right um so
we we we got a chunk of of money from
the house of representatives that is
languishing now uh with mitch mcconnell
not wanting to bring it to a vote but um
one of the things we said was and you do
have to have simultaneously the ability
for a school district to deliver
distance learning
um and so we asked for all kinds of
funding for a family to be able to bring
wi-fi into their home that's like indoor
plumbing now
you know just uh there were there were
two and and and guess what not
everybody's mom has a laptop uh and has
an extra tablet uh sitting around the
house um
we kind of take that for granted that
well everyone has
no stop thinking everyone has just
because you have it
and so uh we there's some extra money
four billion dollars that would help
with the technology that could deliver
uh um
distance learning especially to the
neediest families who are least likely
to be able to afford things like an
extra tablet and and wi-fi in their home
when you know when we ran out of those
school buildings
120 000 school buildings uh back in
march like someone pulled the fire alarm
and you know all all simultaneously 120
000 school you know
uh buildings emptied out
it wasn't for the fun of it
it was because
infectious disease uh medical experts
said this is a pandemic
it is growing we have to do something to
stop infecting each other and a school
is like the worst place to do something
like that so we left
um and within a day
we had people uh who um were not trained
in delivering virtual classes saying all
right what's this thing called zoom what
are we doing here what what's and and
they were going online and they were
getting information and they were
connecting with each other uh my
organization we were just bombarded with
people saying what you got i got to do
this tomorrow and i've got third graders
or i've got a calculus class
or i've got special ed students
or i've got kids that don't speak
english
and i've got to deliver instruction and
sometimes services and sometimes lunch
to these kids because that's what a
school is it's a community
and it does take a village to to deliver
what those kids need sometimes that
school nurse is there that family's
primary care physician
because they can't afford uh to go to
the doctor
so we took all of that uh we pulled it
together oh my lord it wasn't perfect it
was frustrating it's still frustrating
um but we knew
in may people were saying
this is going in the wrong direction
this is not going to be okay now they
told us the warm weather would clear it
all
no didn't clear it all up and uh in fact
they opened up some places
uh inside that they shouldn't have and
folks rushed into the bar
and they should have known better
and they ended up getting sick getting
other people sick who went to work who
sat on a bus who did what people do
and all of a sudden things are spiking
all over the country so it became very
very clear
to teachers to school boards uh and even
to governors okay this is not going away
what are we gonna do in august and
september as schools start to reopen
and that's when we it was in may we went
to the house and said you've got to give
us some money for technology for home
technology for kids that don't have
access don't have opportunity we were
delivering to some of these kids paper
packets of worksheets i hate worksheets
but it was all we could do
uh
the only technology in some homes was
mom's telephone
and she took it to work with her because
she had a service job uh stacking
grocery shelves or something and we
couldn't even
call on the telephone our students and
find out how they were doing or give
them some instruction
and
we're still just appalled that in may
we had we thought we were on a fast
track to getting this and and it's still
sitting in the senate
so um
abandon all hope you know something
coming from the senate that's going to
get to these kids in time schools are
already
opening
and they didn't do it right and those
schools many of them are already closing
and it's causing chaos in families when
we could have had a plan we could have
it didn't have to be like this
but now we're still
trying to figure out um now in some
places in nebraska one of my colleagues
called and said we know which of our
kids didn't have wi-fi we just lost them
so now we're working with local
television stations we're just talking
about you know you've got a you've got a
10 antenna on your on your old-fashioned
tv it's not even cable um but some of
the tv stations are giving us an hour
where we could say this is for younger
grades this is for middle school this is
for high school we're doing some general
project based learning so at least
there's something
at least there's something and the
parents can uh you know tune into it a
television program
um we're doing whatever it takes we wish
that some of the
lawmakers the people that have the purse
strings
we wish that they
would step up and see
that they could be helping us instead of
being the obstacle for getting something
very important done
and what would you think would be kind
of the order let's hope and i agree with
you 100 you know in a world where we're
doing a trillion here and a trillion
there of of stimulus packages uh the
internet connectivity issue is a small
pittance there uh but let's hope that
we're able to get the devices and get
the internet access for a lot of these
students and i know that a lot of school
districts have been doing some heroic
things distributing tens or hundreds of
thousands of devices
even then you know we've been hearing
about there's some subset of kids that
just don't have enough supports at home
maybe not ideal environments you know
five ten percent of kids that even if
they're getting the access they're just
getting disengaged so if we had more
resources where would it go you know
would it go towards you know there's a
question here from janet martin rugrats
on facebook you know are teachers
getting enough support and training they
need to keep students engaged even
excited so you know teacher training is
one element there is um
it's more social supports is another
element i don't know how that how you
deliver that in a world of covid um then
there's obviously online tools and
instruction obviously what we do at khan
academy and and other tools
where do you see you know if you had a
blank check and i know that's a little
bit of daydreaming right now but i would
love you know i i think there might be
an openness hopefully at some point when
people realize how serious this is where
what would be the the order of
operations
and and i'm never going to be one of the
pollyanna let's make you know lemonade
out of this this is horrible and people
are dying and i'm not gonna say oh but
the good news
there's no
no there's no good news here but let me
tell you
the
urgency
uh that it has produced is how important
that basic
teacher training and i know i'm talking
about you know you you said uh you know
like a magic wand or a blank check you
know and i'm saying what if we could go
in a time machine you know to the future
uh i know that this is the long game
this is the long term
but um
we need it we need
how to engage with
teaching
on technology distance learning what
that looks like if you're an art teacher
if you're a calculus teacher if you're a
third grade teacher
i'm a sixth grade teacher and
i know that you
will be impressed to learn that i have a
master's degree in instructional
technology which i got on an atari 800
in 1983. so uh yeah i need to like up
up my game just a tiny bit uh i can do
oregon trail like nobody's business but
i'm thinking that maybe
maybe i could upgrade
um
most of us
uh unless you were um in a special
program that did distance learning for
kids in
rural areas we we do have some some
educators who their specialty
is distance learning
now we have to look at this like
technology is your is your blackboard
technology is your you know is is the
chalk you use
it's it's how you have to deliver this
isn't going to be the first time and the
last time that we have some kind of
emergency where kids uh where they can't
walk into that school building we've
done things with snow days and there's a
hurricane or a tornado i mean we've
we've had these horrible crises where
where the school got blown away look at
how long katrina took to recover from
and there was no plan b for these kids
so now maybe
our eyes are open
that becoming a teacher means you know
about your subject you know how to teach
that subject and those are two different
things by the way
and you know all the tools
that you may have to use to teach that
subject and technology is going to be
more and more important that we become
comfortable with it
and that we understand how important it
is to have that technology in a child's
home so that they can do their homework
not just in case of a
a global pandemic but we've always known
that the homework gap
mimics
the technology gap
in that child's living space in that
child's home
and
that there are kids who have
wonderful tools they have access i would
take anything away from anybody
but it was important for those kids and
their parents
were able to afford it and saying yep
this is really really important for my
kid to succeed they're right it's
important for all kids to have that
access and that opportunity and just
like we would say in the school building
for those kids we we fight for a kid's
access to a school nurse a librarian a
counselor
the arts um the the broad range of of
programs that every child needs and now
they're all going to need
access not just to the equipment that's
actually the easy part but access to a
professional
who knows what she or he
is doing
to
make sure that those kids
who are learning that way
are being taught well
it's not my favorite way to teach it
really isn't i love to hug kids
i can't do that now
and i don't want them to fall behind
and i want them to be safe so if i'm a
true professional i have to say all
right on a dime i know how to best use
this technology i know the do's and
don'ts
and i know
what my audience what my my students
need for me
and sometimes they need a hug
and sometimes they need me to know how
to engage them
on a screen that they're looking at i
want those things
and what do you think that could look
like obviously you know
we can't do a paint the full picture but
sketch what it looks like cause i think
to your point everyone's been talking
about
you know just the social distancing and
do we open our clothes and then the next
level they've been talking about um
device access but there hasn't been a
lot of conversation about just what does
what does at least adequate we don't
even have to talk about great but what
does an adequate experience look like
in this world you know if you could
sketch you know what would be your
expectations for your own children or if
you were in the classroom teaching a six
free classroom how would you run your
classroom in math or or english or
social sciences right now
well one of the things that we know is a
great advantage to our students is to
have mom or dad
or a big brother or sister
um helping them
especially if you're dealing with
younger kids but i think it's the same
with older kids too
where they don't plug in or they don't
engage
and
part of it may be
that we need to
know how to develop
better
pacing and better
lesson plans and things that are meant
to be
engaging on that screen right now for a
lot of our teachers it was all right
we've got you know a free zoom or we've
got to free something and i'll go do
whatever you were doing with your 35
kids
uh yesterday and now just do the same
thing uh looking at them is sitting in
35 different kitchens on their
tablets and laptops and we know that
that's that's not the best pedagogy
we know that you have to engage kids and
you have to ask them questions and they
have to be able to ask questions and
interact with each other and there's
ways that we can do that
nea is actually giving some
webinars for teachers on that have never
taught online that are saying i just
need a i need a primer on this i don't
know uh the first thing about uh what
this format can do or my district is
using this kind of platform and i don't
know what a platform is so i mean we're
talking about strict strict beginners
and um doing some webinars anybody that
wants to find out more about what nea is
just putting out there free it's
nea.org slash coveted action because
these are the actions that many of our
members thousands and thousands have
said if you can do anything for me just
help me know what the options are
because i i don't want to just look at a
screen
and
uh
recite from a textbook i
i know what i'm doing when i'm with
those kids
how do i get to something that looks
like that
online
um
and so
again i'm not an expert in that but
we're putting some of the teachers that
have done this before
and we want to look at what you're doing
sal with you know with your um um
online experience because people are
uh desperate
to say
um if i don't know what i know what i'm
supposed to know i gotta learn it and i
got a short time to really ramp this up
because
we don't want
to close teaching and learning i've had
too many reporters who've said you know
are you for closing the schools or are
you going to call and the whole thing
it's like this is the building
and yeah we don't want the building to
be unsafe unhealthy we don't want to
rush into a place that they told us to
rush out of because it wasn't safe so
let's get that part right but we don't
want to close teaching and learning
those kids need us they need us to
deliver instruction they need us to
deliver services they need us to deliver
lunch so we're trying to
we're trying to develop our own plan as
a learning community sometimes school by
school or district by district
um and
along with all of those practical things
i want to know how to use this
so that my kids
get all i can give them and it's it for
us it's not like uh
another reporter said are you scared
that now that everyone knows how easy it
is to teach you know to teach online and
that parents are just
they know how easy it is to uh just turn
on their their computer and i went you
know talk to some of those parents
because they're the ones that are
begging the schools to please open up
it's not easy it's hard to be a teacher
it's hard to do this right we love our
work we're professionals at it we put a
lot of sweat equity into it
it's a labor of love for us and it is
for those parents as well we want to get
it right and we're that's what we're
committed to and the i don't have a
magic wand and it's going to look very
very different in every community and by
the way there are some communities this
is the most creative one
uh that's online learning uh that i've
heard of and it's in maryland it's a
state the state of maryland they have a
plan whoa
um so they're the outlier
uh but their plan was
look we probably could open this
building it's super disinfected with all
the masks and and those health
screenings but we can put a small
fraction
of the kids in here and socially
distance so they said so let's go with
that
we're going to
do distance learning
um we are going to have a plan for
distance learning so that it's not just
you know we're closing school tomorrow
go do distance learning everyone has
planned for this
we're going to plan on how we're going
to deliver those lunches and those
homework packets we're going to use the
buses in a reverse way they're going to
be delivering things to the kids homes
not picking up the kids to go to school
and so all hands on deck they're all
doing it but they said
there are some kids who might not have
mom and dad at home
you know we can hand them a laptop
we might even be able to set up some
kind of wi-fi broadband in a parking lot
somewhere
where but mom and dad aren't there to
bring the kids
uh to download something in a parking
lot
uh they're not there to explain to a
second or third grader what it is that
we're doing so they're going to open up
their schools to those kids who need the
most who don't have it in their homes
and they're not giving in-person
instruction to those kids
those kids are opening up the school uh
laptop and tablets
um there there's adult supervision
but the teacher is online
and it's it's some of the
paraprofessionals who are saying all
right i can help you like your mom or
dad would be helping you if they had a
job where they were working from home or
had access to that
and for those teachers that are teaching
special education kids
um especially the medical medically
fragile kids
uh who need so much
and they're in a very
specific
atmosphere they're saying we're going to
bring those kids in they're very few of
them we can distance we can disinfect uh
and we're not opening the school
but we're making sure that everybody has
access
to what the most fortunate kids uh have
access to so i'm i'm so proud of
educators and there are lots of school
boards that are listening to us
as they say all right dr fauci says it's
not ready to open the school
we still want teaching and learning
going on you're the professionals
tell us how we can do this safely
and do it competently
and it's happening in more places than
you'd think
what makes the news
is we did it wrong we opened the school
hundreds of kids got sick we click front
page news
um
and it is a cautionary tale it should be
front page news but those places that
have quietly done it the way they were
supposed to they listened to medical
experts they listened to education
experts they said parents what can you
do in your homes what can't you do in
your homes
those are the places that are quietly
showing us the way forward
and
maybe we can give a little more
attention to the
not just the cautionary tales but the
success stories
no i love that the example you gave
maryland actually hadn't heard of it and
i hadn't heard of that model but it
makes a ton of sense and it's gonna i'm
gonna add that to my talk track of ideas
for folks i also giggled a little bit
because i also get the question that you
i guess got around will distance
learning replace teachers and all of
that and you know i almost laugh every
time i hear that because you know i'm
sometimes a bit of a poster child for
online learning or whatever else and i'm
the first one to say if i had to pick
between a live teacher and technology i
would pick the live teacher any day for
my kids or anyone else's kids and pure
distance learning is not a good solution
for the great majority of students what
we should be thinking about is how do we
get all of the power of an amazing
teacher
especially ideally once we're post
pandemic in person so that you have that
you're sharing a room you can have that
hug you can have that human human
connection
and then think about how tools can be in
service once again not technology for
technology's sake but technology and
service to true
pedagogical or social emotional goals so
it couldn't be more aligned and you know
i'd love to go offline
and talk about how we can help because i
think we're we're we're very aligned on
this you know just in in the remaining
time we have um
what do you think
you know everything we we're describing
this is clearly a sub-optimal year not
everyone's going to be able to do what
maryland did uh there's going to be kids
that are are
are going to fall further behind not be
supported
it's probably this year's probably going
to drive more inequity not less
what do you think is going to be the
outcome of it if we're talking about you
know if we're having this conversation
in five years or we say yeah covet
changed a lot and this is what the
outcome of it was positive negative i'd
love to
you know put your your prognostication
hat you know what what are we going to
be looking at permanently in the
education system or in society because
of this
i really appreciate the gravity of that
question
and i don't think we ask it enough
we're going to look back on this
year as a lost year for so many kids
because
of
[Music]
the political
lack of will to take this seriously and
to do what needed to be done
um the magical thinking
of too many
um
key political figures
local state and national
has devastated lives
and not just the people who lost someone
lost their health or their life to to
covet but these school children
we it i just keep saying this because i
have you can't see it because i i turned
my computer away from the wall that i
have punched several holes in
just so upset and so angry
at the
poor judgment
of the
the magical thinking of politicians who
got really really good advice i'm a
sixth grade teacher i understood that
advice i understood
i'm not i'm not a scientist
but anybody could explain
or listen to the explanation and say
well yeah that makes sense and these
politicians that have could have done
something about it i hate to just dwell
on that but
um
these kids have been sacrificed
to
the bad judgment of too many politicians
and i
want to make it my life's mission
to try and recapture some of
their
loss this year
and it's going to be a really tough job
what we should be doing going forward i
think with new and better decisions
uh will be what are we going to go back
and take especially
those kids
that had access and opportunity to
nothing if anything i'm not even just
talking about well look at all the folks
that didn't get to go to their
graduation party yeah that's really sad
i'm you know i'm not talking about that
i'm talking about someone you only get
one year to be a first grader
you only get one year to put the you
know the consonants and the vowels
together and have it click and go i get
it this is called reading oh my lord and
to have fun
so that you make reading something that
you just do because you love it
um
for some of these kids we're going to
have to go back and give them something
extra
and give them something um
not just remedial but something where we
say you're the kids that we're not going
to put in an overcrowded classroom and
expect to get caught up
you're the kids that we are going to
prioritize the tools and the techniques
and the programs that we're going to be
doing with you
that are going to incorporate the arts
and sports and field trips we're going
to do something to bring joy into your
learning experience that was lost
because of this last year
funding for public schools has been
miserable for so long
and i
i reject uh people who well meaningly
they will you know
think they're saying something wrong and
they say
schools are the fundamental you know
foundation of our of our economy it's
our best investment all right so yes
and for me that's like four on the list
it's a human and civil right
to an education i don't care if that
choir puts one dime into the economy it
was that child's right to have that
experience it is the foundation of our
democracy
of being a good
citizen of being a good neighbor being a
good
parent a good human being
so there's so much wrapped up in
that public school i'm gonna start
crying
we forget that
and we think of it as a transactional
piece of the economy
it's so much bigger than that
and we have got we owe
we owe
this last year
to millions of kids and we should make
that a national priority
well no i i couldn't agree with you more
lilly and you know i'm i'm saying this
completely generally you know view khan
academy as you know in service to you
and all of the teachers uh that you're
representing uh you know we we view
ourselves that way and especially in
this crisis we want to do whatever we
can to mitigate the the uh the
sub-optimality of what we're all facing
this coming year and to help mitigate
and and close whatever gaps we can in
the in the the in the aftermath of
whatever all of this is uh but really
appreciate the conversation i learned a
ton and i hope that this is the start of
our conversations together
absolutely thank you so much for having
me
thanks so much lily
well thank you all for joining what i
you know again of a fascinating
conversation the whole world is going
through a very tough
set of circumstances right now but i
think the school
issue and the ability to make sure that
inequity doesn't grow
as we go through school closures or
physical school closures as lilly
mentioned we're going to hopefully
continue to educate kids in any ways we
can
it's a it's i think it's the issue of
our day uh you know that and the
economics and the education one in a lot
of ways uh might be more important even
than the economics because it has very
long lasting implications uh so thanks
so much for joining uh this conversation
and i look forward to seeing you all uh
later this week for more of uh this
homeroom live stream thanks everyone
you